ready for it he brings them up this is
it
drop up keep it simple there it is go
Ichi your Dragonball fighters 2019 Evo
champion after overcoming hand injury
he's in tears up there defeating sonic
Fox to claim victory here
well the winners side nonetheless and
know the real tears right there this has
been eluding him for so long last year
he reset the bracket sonic Fox plush it
out Luigi somehow just what is very
first championship for this game after
being so dominant for so long well
another Evo has come and gone the
world's most prestigious fighting game
tournament gets bigger every year and in
2019 we of course had nine main stage
games ten streams over 14,000 non-unique
entries over the course of three days
now if you missed any of that or you're
just an Evo withdrawal like the rest of
us well don't worry we got you covered
this video is gonna have the sickest
plays the best Popoff's the most
improbable comebacks as well as a little
section i snuck in at the end that's
kind of an homage to some of the side
games we retreated to on the Evo streams
on Saturday now let's cut this intro
short and get to what you actually came
here for starting with the best pops
from Evo
you got it you got it and there's a pump
ball football goes to the crowd New York
isn't filled it what's up the NL VC
hopefuls put in the work and Twinkies
gonna take it like a champ with a smile
on its face there's the handshake don't
smile after that though oh my goodness
no not like that
I am NOT losing
wait up a cup 300 my word
does that mean pop wasn't walking in
those exclamation mark but I mean there
it is look at this look at AMERICA
AMERICA be look at this I twelve win
it's purple and man defeating the
Japanese invasion and she will plow my
he is going for it right now
okay quickly finishes off our fellow
commentator well Chris good stuff for
getting on stage be popping off right
there yo get the grand finals three one
over who though Alito you know he
thought he'd be good because he you just
do you just do it the eggs orb and then
it's really hard to get those break your
combo right but I've been doing a super
invincible alright so as you saw the
presence of my fairly than 1mb et al
Padre shanks Calvo la forma completa
finally qualifies to evil to paint
historical area as his boys - wait for
the first time in fighting in history a
Spanish player will be representing
españa in top eight follow the letter B
living in the hey Nia you only need one
every capital it is turned out for them
turn the chops here from Alito changer
should we wear hijab it hey guys can you
believe some of those decisions there
that set was godly I cannot believe it
remains is separating is your place blue
cross that battle champion here he wrote
2093 o in the second set of the bread
model looked like Cammy was gonna
dominate him right he hand them that
person and then Xingu adaptation to me
oh he is hiked my god America has done
it Gianna I never thought I'd be alive
to see the day huh America winning and
animate ornament here at Evo 2019 what's
gonna happen right now he looking for
this opportunity holding my breath oh
they trade blows Oh
that was a crazy trade Arslan cementing
his position as the best second player
on the planet untouchable by any country
that he has faced thus far very very
nice
so fact is he likes it very like I said
you can't even counter that no way
Carson - your ego check work Luke is not
even in this galaxy of work bro he's
still undefeated again - oh he makes a
grand finals evil 2019 he clutches it
out last year he took the eldest time
he's in winterside grand finals
one more set for him and he's exhausted
now - have a great pop off it does help
to make a great play beforehand this
next section is basically just a mash-up
of all the coolest pipe [ __ ] that we saw
an Evo this year the least expected way
to use that meter nice blocks it's the
nice mental destruction that somebody
like Reynolds people oh he gets the
webbing catch crime a little bit to grab
happy has to remember he has totes
he has Ariel suited man to fare the bear
you can definitely make it a little bit
difficult oh wait oh especially yo that
was cert
okay broom it look at that accuracy oh
he should I go for it together there we
go this time we duct those great choice
by blue take his turn back there sole
charge potential beyblade nope goes for
the walls black combo Oh
the big damage innit - here we go see
how much the scale but there's no way
this doesn't kill oh my god it's gonna
kill let it rip mix up with that I like
it
he's Sam though feel like the icon with
Pikachu out here before reasons like
this it's awesome
he uses his junk but he still can't make
it back alright you Sam you can't let's
see how he capitalizes up this yeah a
little bit on safe on shield and so much
damage for an unsafe versus I see oh I'm
taking him for a ride yeah complete 180
once again boats European she's pushing
him on to the air here comes the back
here we'll do a 10% of JP ex-soldiers
target got on the beach I literally
cannot breathe I have not breathe lose
you Toto takes it you taupe so it was so
smart that jumps up just the kids skill
went for another two K that would have
tech jumped it ice block their total
yeah get a tomato lathe oh my god
he only numbered his buddy's car I'm
dead shopping this computer right now
here we go to the triangle double bar
head plug the J go blue
you don't you are yvonne 2019 champion
of song caliber six there's an i'm
reading on the truck I would mix this
kid I don't care I respect us you're
here for the games you are mixing the
kidnap whether you guide your girl you
is kid you unknown guy whatever your age
is you're here to get mix that is white
findings or something so bright but sit
on Yoshi Yoshi Yoshi will get his win
here like on the biggest stage biggest
tournament in the world and the little
kid Tsuyoshi gets the win here this is
evil guys this is fighting game such a
warm feeling to see that you know that
water matters ball he might be dead he
might actually be he's dead he's dead
the damage guys don't even done fools
diamond done doubt it that's almost 60
58 Oh 59 that was excited every ball
that was dis gusting chichi Kokua [ __ ]
Spartacus care for the Spanish go slow
sonic wants to run Bart off to the
office instead of the GT Goku air - mix
up needs to be careful with those
vanishes I can tell you right now he
might get too aged misty air - castle
greet you with a challenge GZ Goku
assist hold the vanish sandwich and some
back goals for the overhead mix-up look
at the deep it from Luigi oh my God he's
gonna out block the entire sparkly how
is he still doing this right now
reflects out he survived the urns there
Mariah still landing in front of him -
yes sir let me tell you something right
now
oh [ __ ] I can't believe he did that
the time Oh fix up what you do
has matured immensely we saw yesterday
my god wait wait no way
no what only be at the spike but he's
still gonna go give the pants I beat up
he no no not like that
what a way to start off the second
emphatic zero to death for proto bad a
great opportunity scare all the time
anything to do it here and he's in a
weapon flip the potential for the run
grab he's got up perhaps maybe try to
fall off the back down stand he's
looking for
I'm already gonna blow my voice gets the
Becker he's gonna try to stop the Razor
Leaf it knocks them off the pike but
it's not enough he reads the rollin
that's way it's going to grant fight off
Fujiwara can kill at this point in time
but Big Bird will just do a lot of
damage and catch up an item faded it out
faded out the e^x spinning mixer knew he
was under the big pressure again at the
end these two running into each other
again through finals he's waving him
over he's like let's play right now I'm
ready on come on you I want you come on
come sit down buddy go have a talk with
uncle furry gonna tell you gerrae
go itches like all this got one more
chance
this is moment your breath champion for
evolution 2019
right through all pretty private
oh man that could have been in try you
trying to burst it to his late got to be
careful here they're proud it's a little
done day before throw break so clutch oh
that's gonna hurt
he had rage he wanna get the kill with
the law said look at him so tricky
hitting it with the bike this could be
in if he chases him off but no he's
gonna give him the proper respect break
the rule in ex Luton he defeats right so
with the read of the century my man was
so ready right over a little bit hurt
but it's okay that was winners sides are
still hanging on to this for a little
bit longer man he is a God then a
counter as well to avoid the edge week
is so far ahead of playoff now
nothing gets us popping out of our seats
and screaming at our monitors like an
improbable comeback and of course the
best fgc and smash competitors in the
world just never give up after all if
you have just a pixel of health left you
can make magic happen here are the best
comebacks from Evo of 2019 yo there it
is I know that wasn't me was that a
media SPG that was gone like oh and try
to tick oh wow you're going for the city
[Music]
okay come here
whoa don't throw the donut donut on
anything or you aji these doughnuts hey
see the doughnut that evokes it doesn't
get hit by the shipper mrs. Addie Peter
one more hit for corrosiveness to me and
he can take this round it's gonna get
full corner
and then phones can have the block
whatever this mix-up is okay what is it
overhead on the fact that the end who
thought was killing himself at the
replay getting time to see Chris get in
and get hit with that same strike old
for the super dance after they jumped
into the Karloff there's a bandage I've
been at your advantage back to the court
what a pickup beef it's still in this
Wow most definitely is he gets the air
to hair conversion Christy down to his
last character he was so much leader on
his side as well to play with is
definitely in favor of 6mm he would bets
- Oh in winner's bracket my cut what a
call out what a call [ __ ] one more hit
is all you need in that Jim's old
guaranteed all right here's a chance
crushing blow yes
it hasn't start one out of three let's
count it he's got more bets right now he
wants a hold on that comeback head in
oh yeah he is all over a fire wall that
was the way to punish run a foot stomp
Oh Kazami with the raise drop into top
one gallon dad man is taking a neat oh
yeah he's got all the bars all the bars
on his phone Oh sob oh my goodness oh my
goodness this man broke in the bank and
took everything
good god he took the deposits every day
[Music]
oh boy oh boy you could be dead now he's
taking it on the chin what's it all
about
awkward timing scramble throw he called
it out free oh no buddy it should be
don't know one more mix out of the wall
splash oh did you just exit I did hexam
he'd you just accident filipino hex oh
my bad
[ __ ] opera goes down to race he's got
the range bark man I'm sorry the Roma I
did it Wow unbelievable miracle comeback
they're getting real out here too much
noise oh no the big poop is too much
noise arson task with the raid that's
all it's gonna oh my god going on here
the throw bang oh wow he woke it already
for it
he was so ready for that debugger and
man the low parry this is the first time
these guys have been up in the world
week meets one more stock and now it
back here knocking a weak spot what is
the option now you get nothing to let go
oh my god did he do it
fourth row he's going to survive leo has
are sent out this could go either way
so Evo isn't just about top eights and
Sunday games there are a ton of side
tournaments that run all throughout the
weekend and we wanted to give them some
love to so from super turbo to a little
game you might have heard of called
smash bros melee here's our little love
letter to the side games from evo 2019
so grace still up remember he still has
a full life bar after this
that was that was ballsy hi air - she's
not doing an instant air - that means
that the jump age the hip hop's
on the bottom part of it is actually
clubbing and Marland by out of his hover
bath yeah and so it's working out in
dividends right now that is exactly what
Dabney the feel that it's like I know
what you're going to do let me show you
something real quick child I'm actually
see it if you could if he stays on the
Claire for too long he's probably gonna
break the glass into it all right
Wow he has been ready for it though with
an arrow that was so smart players
Oh Oh follow up dead dead what what that
didn't hit twice so i am i all-round
only the hand was it because it was a
medium boy so vicki OS whose point set
Sarah Bart's getting in with those kids
turning back with rain we got it all
right maybe it might be a job it's a lot
of reps a lot of rest but Vicky's in
there right now that's not a good way to
start the match that's just discouraging
but sometimes you have to accept
sometimes that's how the game will go we
powered up with that last missile whoo
just wait a second he killed both of
them
oh my god Joey throws okay this is the
first so the first player priority gave
him that throw and it turns out that Rob
purposes game paid up in the longest run
impossible oh yeah they kind of forgot
his rappel to go back on stage she with
the crab and the wobble that's the
second stop will we nothing is the
grabby Jump Street that's so fast for
then well I wonder if the angle that
he's launched actually take the rock
behind him or is
- gonna keep wobbling him until the
stage trance that is a third grab as a
third wobble and that is to zero for
chudan bum wipe you had his time on the
stage and she was walking you out yeah
welcome to Evo 2 0 plug Y p-- it's
looking bad for out here right now he
needs to get out of that corner both
players have max super so this could
still be even see look look he's dipping
them he's dipping them away already
oh there we go got him in the corner but
that doesn't mean that super moves on
what with no life no hell no help
well guys that's about it now there was
no shortage of incredible moments to
choose from from this year's evolution
but those were just some of our
favorites now I do have to say that Evo
isn't all about lower bracket runs and
hype Popoff's it's also about friends
and fun and we've got an entire video
dedicated to the best funny moments and
fails from Evo this year coming out very
soon now until it does come out don't
forget to like this video sub to the
channel if you appreciate the content
and I will see you in the comment
section thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification fell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]